Hi. I'm Antoine Fuqua,
the director of The Guilty.
911. Emergency operator 625.
What is the address
of the emergency?
-Hi, sweetie.
-Sorry, you called 911.
One of my favourite scenes
to film
would probably be when
Riley calls in, the actress.
It's the first time
she says:
"I want to talk, sweetie."
While he's dealing with
a woman that's obviously
been kidnapped
and is in danger,
his phone is ringing.
And his little girl's
on the phone.
And he's trying to
make a decision
to talk to his little girl,
who he's very close to,
but he's divorced.
And, at the same time,
a reporter calls in.
This is Joe.
Joe, hey.
Do you have time to answer
a couple of questions
about tomorrow?
Who is this?
Are you a journalist?
All this is kind of
happening
while he's dealing with
a kidnapped woman
that's come in.
How do you desperately
help someone that's in need?
How do you have
the discipline
not to pick up the phone
when your little girl,
when you've been trying to
call her all day,
your ex-wife won't let you
speak to her…
And then you have
a reporter calling you
wanting to know
your side of the story
of something you did wrong.
To me,
that's a complex scene.
And, in filming that scene,
I had to restrain myself
because there's a tendency
to want to do
a lot of things
with the camera.
The discipline for me was
not to move the camera.
To just be there with him
and let the actor do it.
I told Jake: "I'm going to
stay wide for a lot of it."
"And then
I'm just going to march in."
"Closer, closer, closer."
To make the audience,
sort of,
have some distance
from what's happening.
Until she calls.
And, once she calls,
I go really close.
Right in here
and you can see his eyes
darting back and forth
as he's trying to process
what the woman's saying.
Who is that?
-Yes, I understand.
-Is there someone with you?
As he's trying to register
in his brain visually
what's happening to her,
the audience starts to do
the same
and it makes you
lean in more to listen
to what's being said.
They're not in the room
with me.
They're on Zoom.
They're in whatever world
they're in, right?
So, they would call in.
We had specific times.
For actors, we're going to
do 20 minutes today.
And I can see them
in their homes
and wherever they were.
Jake could never see them.
And so, they would get
their cue from me
and then they would go
into their performance
as he answered the call.
But the actors that called
in were amazing:
Ethan Hawke
and Peter Sarsgaard
and Riley and Da'Vine.
It's just, like,
a blessing to have
those kinds of actors.
Paul Dano…
Their performance makes
Jake's performance better
because,
if he doesn't believe them,
we don't believe them.
Most of us have been there
before in some way
where you can't get people
to do
what you want over the phone
and you can't do anything
about it.
An emotional person like Joe
who doesn't really do this,
he's a street cop,
is not used to that rhythm.
Shit.
He doesn't know how to deal
with all these emotions.
-Fuck me?
-Fuck you! Go to hell.
Alright, yeah. Fuck you!
And he's expecting everybody
to move
when he wants them to move
and get helicopters in there
and do all these things
and that's just
not the way it works.
So that builds tension.
It's frustrating,
a bit, as a director
because, you know, you're
a slave to the technology.
You know, so, if the Zoom
glitches, which it did,
if someone down the street
is making noise…
In New York City,
while someone's doing
their side of things,
you can't control
any of that.
Glitches happening…
So, anything that
you were feeling,
especially Jake,
would wind up on the screen.
He would get…
his own voice in his ear.
And he would just sometimes,
just:
"I can't…
This is driving me crazy."
And I would keep the camera
rolling
and he'd kind of
get back into it again
and some of that's in
the cut because it was real.
You know,
I always use lighting
as another character.
The city itself is
a character, you know.
The first shot of the sunset
with L.A. on fire,
for me, is Dante's Inferno
and it sets off an urgency.
The lighting on the inside
when we first meet Joe…
It's daytime. It's sort of
a soft glow light.
Sort of like purgatory.
It's a non-lighting.
It sort of just
floats there, right?
Later, as it gets darker,
when you see
the Alka-Seltzer
glass
when he comes
from calling his daughter,
it's darker
when he goes back in.
So, subconsciously
when you see that way
towards the blinds,
it's now darker than
what you saw before.
But, at the same time,
the subject matter's getting
darker
because she's now called in.
911. Emergency operator 625.
What is the address
of the emergency?
And, every time an audience
sees the red light,
red is violence.
That just feels urgent.
So, those big close-ups
of the red light were
to make you feel
that urgency.
When he goes
into the other room,
that whole room is dark
except for
the little pin light
because his character's
getting darker.
Right?
The beginning of the movie
when he's in the bathroom is
all white because it's
the beginning of purgatory.
You're in the clouds.
He's not quite anywhere.
But he's suffering.
When he goes back
in the bathroom,
he's kind of green.
The concept is like a snake
just getting tighter
and tighter and tighter
and we're watching
a man dying, right?
Because he's guilty
and he's hiding it.
But it's coming
out of his body
and he's coughing and it's
starting to ooze out of him.
He can't escape it.
And, if you look at the man,
he's very sweaty
and he looks pale.
And a little green.
He looks like death.
I had a list of things I was
going to possibly shoot
to take you to some of the
worlds that you're hearing.
And then,
when I cut it together,
it would completely
go against what the film is.
The audience imagination
is way stronger
than anything that
I designed to shoot.
People created that story.
I learnt to trust that more,
to trust an audience
imagination more.
Yeah, I think
that's the biggest thing.
Thank you for watching
The Guilty.
Only on Netflix.